[Applause]
CBS morning's Tony decopo our dear
friend is here
we've got Tony I know can we keep Tony
every day
we love you so much can I go first yeah
do it take it go for it all right here
we go first up Insider reports of Hugh
Jackman who recently concluded an
11-month rod on Broadway starring in The
Music Man I saw him he was wonderful
he was terrific he said though he
actually thinks he did permanent damage
to his vocal cords from all the growling
he did his Wolverine in the X-Men movies
oh wow wow look at that image oh hi
hello so that's not a tattoo there
that's sorry about the voice uh but
thanks for your service
[Laughter]
yeah I know
he turned down the role of Wolverine I
was like my voice is too important to me
I'm not gonna do it plus I was less
Wolverine and more benverine you know
what I mean
do you have a woman
a wolf like to debut here well does
anyone remember how
it's sort of a scratchy
[Music]
sorry Tony what was that and I actually
think it was good that no one really
heard it no I want to hear it I'm gonna
keep that one trapped inside one more
little wow
[Applause]
I love it how would you do Wolverine
we have a different take an artistic
impression I love it I love a good hiss
I have all the time it really gets the
point across all right next Apartment
Therapy reports on the most romantic
thing that you can add to your bedroom
according to sex Birds you want to hear
what it is yeah yeah you do it's a
full-length mirror located where I know
that's what I asked are we talking wall
ceiling they say it's a huge turn on to
watch how your partner's body reacts to
touches in a mirror so Ross Tony miras
do it for you that'd be a no for
Matthews I'm good listen I find missing
you but I do not want to risk seeing me
you know like that is there's a time for
self-reflection and when your nude is
not it dear that is not the time you are
a lights off lover then that would mean
lights off can I put on an eye mask I'm
good with that
hey there's a kink to that I didn't mean
it like that oh there's a whole group
they've done with eye masks maybe I do
mean it like that or to Not Mirror uh we
do have a stand-up mirror and I do think
it is exciting for a couple reasons why
the lights on I think do work and I love
lights on and secondly I I find not the
touch being what I like seeing reflected
but when when my wife is standing in
front of the mirror whether she's
getting ready for something or ending
her day seeing her look at herself and
seeing the reflection is like me looking
at her from the outside but then I get
to step into the scene and that Dynamic
do you see what I'm saying
I think it's still
low you and your wife are serious goals
we are we are Deeply Madly wildly
crazily in love uh and and
you know when I say I don't know I've
been single for so many years I just
don't know you so you always encourage
me to be open-minded and that there's
great love out there and that it's you
know it's your truth and the truth
exists and we need people like that in
our lives to keep us Believers and
mating in captivity is Possible Oh
married sex is still with very good sex
yeah isn't it really yeah
all right next up Associated Press
reports if you don't like the way your
signature looks you know when you write
your name well you can now pay a
signature doctor to create a new one for
you Prices range from ten dollars to a
few hundred bucks and they usually
include instructional sheets and videos
so you can perfect your new John Hancock
and if you want a new signature
signature
um they say you should practice for
three days 15 minutes to 20 minutes a
day and you can perfect it once they
create one for you would you want a new
one I don't know what you I mean what
are you using a signature for in a
public way I'm used to just signing like
you know receipts with my finger the
digital screen thing yeah I know those
all look the same they're all the same
I've seen people just touch the screen
they just do a little dot yeah yeah
um I think handwriting in general
because we type so much everything now
looks like a serial killer when I write
it it just looks like like it's just
like an EKG like yeah I can't even read
my own writing anymore are you what's
your uh what's your signature like
Barrymore well
that's like my signature and I hate it
looks like be right back yeah it's so
you're totally right depressing and like
when anybody kicks at old school and
actually asks for an autograph of which
I love because it's such a lost art
because you know growing up back in my
day you know they liked autographs there
was no phones you know you signed a
piece of paper and that's what you did
so I have always wanted to improve my
signature and I really might try this
course I think you should because it
does it almost looks like you wrote
dribble it's it is
well that is my awful signature and I'd
like to change it so I appreciate that
story it's a very important book that
Tony and I have been discussing and
we're actually going to make a meal from
it with um his favorite Chef Tamar Adler
it is so meaningful it's about how you
approach leftovers that's right and we
all have that Real Deal leftovers and
she is a chef and she's super fancy but
this is the cook who taught me how to be
a cook wow also you can go in the index
and look up the leftover you have and
then she gives you all these imaginative
ways it stops food waste this is so
important I can't wait let's go to the
kitchen let's do it
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]